there was some Believers and some
non-believers
we used to have sightings where a Finn
might be seen cruising past
which probably at the time was a little
bit unbelievable
stories became a legend
over a period of time with a lot of
people reporting these sightings I guess
it became known that there must be
something there
after weeks of tall tales
this picture emerges and that that
picture made it into the local paper and
gave the The Legend story a little bit
more substance you're probably thinking
it's a bit of a crazy story to have
large sharks just hanging around in a
lake on a golf course
[Music]
Scott Wagstaff is one of a growing
number of people who find sharks where
they least expect them
I think the reality is until you see the
shark for yourself for the first time
it's very difficult to believe the story
doesn't make a lot of sense really
[Music]
rumors of golf course sharks swirl
course manager Scott Wagstaff
investigates
he figures any shark stuck in a lake may
be hungry
within minutes
a shark shows itself
I'm so excited as I can't believe I've
finally got this this video footage of a
shark I'm literally only probably two
meters away from the shark at this point
it was so close
shark biologist Jasmine Graham has spent
hundreds of hours studying sharks
the fact of the matter is
I don't know where shark might show up
then the mystery deepens experts like
Jasmine can identify individual sharks
by their fins the shark fin in the first
picture is different to the one in
Scott's video there may be two sharks
experts move in and gather more evidence
what they discover
shocks everyone
there's not one or two Golf Course
predators
seven different sharks everyone that
kind of implied our Golf Course wanted
to wanted that opportunity to see a
shark fin as they play that sort of
became
that became the thing here you know did
you see the shark today
the golf is here now no
um that's somewhere where you leave your
ball to rest and you don't go and try
and retrieve it for obvious reasons the
value of someone's life is probably not
worth a golf ball
[Music]
biologists identify The Intruders bull
sharks
bull sharks are one of the three most
dangerous species
they have one of the strongest bite
forces of all sharks
no problem biting through a golf club or
even a golfer
most notably bull sharks have a special
adaptation
they can tolerate fresh water
basically the big issue as to why
certain animals can't go in fresh water
is that their bodies are too salty and
so they actually get a rush of water
into their bodies into their cells that
cause them basically to burst but bull
sharks and some other sharks actually
have the ability to regulate the salt
content in their own bodies so that they
can stay level with the environment
that allows these bull sharks to survive
in a water hazard on a golf course
and to multiply
on a couple of occasions I've had some
shark experts come and view the sharks
they believe because of the size of some
of the sharks so the only way they could
have got into the lake was through a
breeding
the remaining mystery is how the parents
got here in the first place
almost every year the golf course is
devastated by floods
nearby Riverbanks can't contain the
water so the sharks have an open path
whenever there's weather events
sharks usually
barometric
however
storms are coming so usually they're
going to move into areas where they're
at less risk which is probably how these
bull sharks ended up in the pond in the
first place trying to get out of the
path of the storm
when the flood waters recede some bull
sharks have nowhere to go and wind up
stranded in Suburbia
but the Sharks on the golf course found
a lake deep enough to keep swimming
what storms bring in they can also take
away
a more recent flood may have thin the
shark numbers at the 14th hole
now we haven't seen the sharks in the
lake for a little while but I'm not
going in for a swim to find out if
they're still there
I can't walk past the lake without
scanning it for the chance of seeing a
thin break the surface there could very
well be a shark in the lake behind me
right now
[Music]
sharks are in beating beating unexpected
places
[Music]
no one expects to see a great white
shark in a swimming pool
crease legs backyards
[Music]
oh my God
they come close for a reason
now
[Music]
foreign
ER river is a paradise for watermothers
this Estuary is a feeding ground for
fish like Cobb and grunter
shark food
30 miles up this pristine Waterway
holiday maker Simon van helsinkin and
his friends have spent the day swimming
and now hope to catch a few big ones
we go to the greater River every year
and we
Chill on the boat chatting having a
laugh rods are in the water and good
fish I mean we catch probably catching a
grunt every 10 minutes so it's good fun
and it's all catch and release so
so we put them back and really just uh
just a fun outing and until uh yeah
until it got a little bit more serious
basically I hooked into a fish I was
fighting it bringing it up to the boat
and then when it was really really close
to the boats I saw a massive swirl of
water behind the fish and and realized
that's definitely not not a fish so I
told my friend just to grab my phone and
start filming
me
that's what the ground was
coming back
[Music]
all of a sudden when this shock takes
this this ride I mean there's absolutely
nothing you can do it's uh just holding
it and it's just singing that reel is
absolutely singing basically like a boat
and hooked the line and just stripped
the cleared we were just standing there
in shock
oh
[Music]
we're so far away from the ocean the
last thing I expected is a giant shark
stealing my fish I mean I was swimming
this morning I was in the water
right there
this shark swims in a sleepy backyard
Waterway for a reason
renowned shark biologist Allison Towner
studies predatory behavior in sharks of
all sizes
bull sharks are definitely demonstrating
a level of sophistication in their
behavior here because they're working
out that by sitting and waiting for a
fisherman to make a catch they're doing
half of the work for them and then
therefore they can just take an easy
kill
the sharks catch on to easy meals at the
end of fishing lines
sharks are very intelligent and
get these stimuli's that indicate this
tray is going to be easy it's injured
it's sick but they also can be trained
and we've shown this in science that
they actually can be trained to go to
specific targets so they can adapt to
knowing hey this is a place that I know
that I can get this food
just how far Upstream a bull shark will
go for food is anyone's guess in some
cases far enough to invade someone
else's turf
[Music]
in the heart of issy mangaliso Wetland
Park
one of the wildest places on Earth
[Music]
the river teams with dangerous animals
hippos are the world's deadliest large
land animals responsible for around 500
human deaths a year
[Applause]
crocodiles have a bad rep too
adventurers Bevin and Jill Langley are
prepared for both
there is something else
lurking in the water
what is that
it's like Shawn
oh my God
[Applause]
it's chasing for them
what good
whoa
[Applause]
such shark encounters appear to be
getting more and more common
[Music]
local guides Stacy funvig was there when
one turned into an attack
I see my hippo family but suddenly there
was a bit of a splash
I can see the hippos are getting
agitated
they splashing their making a noise
oh
I'm actually getting nervous for the
shark now I'm not sure what's happening
and then all of a sudden the hippo must
have got quite a big truck and the
mother hippo reacted and tried to run
after the shock but because the water
was so shallow at that time the shock
didn't actually disappear it in fact
went the opposite direction and went on
to the mud and then more than one hippo
started chasing the shark
two of the world's deadliest animals
for their Tory thank you
[Music]
the shark gets off with a warning but
leaves both hippos and humans puzzled by
its presence
in a remarkable twist it may be the
hippos that brought the shark here in
the first place
the Sharks were hungry and as we know
hippos go to the toilet in the water and
the best place for young fish to to to
feed is by the hippos so the shark was
getting a little bit Brave and he
decided to go to the hippos to try and
get something to eat and we know hippos
have a little bit of a short temper and
being bumped by a shark and woken up to
see those teeth I think the hippo got a
bit of a fright and he reacted and
started chasing the shark around
yeah
bull sharks hunting around hippos may
seem bizarre but food temps even the
smartest of beasts
on the other side of the planet big
sharks with a bad reputation also get
close to home
then closer
then even closer
first the Magnuson family prepares for a
day of fishing for small macro
foreign
oh my God
white shark maybe 13 feet I'm not
videoing right now holy that's you we're
just talking about my mind is like right
on oh my God don't get the size of that
look at him whoa he could tip the photo
look at him huh
marine scientist Carly Jackson is used
to being surrounded by big sharks
even she finds the Magnuson video
unnerving but not surprising
that shark's head was like bigger than
their boat so sharks usually can't
really tell what's going on at the
surface and they'll need to come up and
investigate
it isn't interested in the baited hook
quick as it appears
it vanishes
just when holiday makers at Cape Cod
think a shark can't get any closer
one does
swimmers regularly enjoy the Tranquil
Salt Ponds of the area
they sing as safe as swimming
and they are unless there's a shark
invasion
around the world great whites are known
as open ocean Travelers
in deep water
breach From Below
but somehow this 14-foot giant gets into
a pond used for leisure
and perhaps strangest of all it won't
leave
big sharks get trapped for a lot of
reasons it could be that the tide was
high enough at the time for them to swim
into the area and maybe they were
chasing prey and then the tide goes down
and the water level drops and then
suddenly this animal doesn't have enough
water to get through the area that it
came through initially
settles in for the day
then the week
then two weeks
residents call in experts to get it out
but everyone is stopped
you can't control a 14-foot great white
shark
the scientists tag her so they can track
her movements beyond the pond
defined a possible exit point and lay
Nets to guide her out
but she refuses to go a shark that big
do whatever it wants to
fresh baked doesn't entice her out
either
they try to catch her
fail
finally they bring in the big guns
water cannons
the shark very slowly but surely moves
away from all of the noise and they're
actually able to steer it by using I
guess the boats and the high pressure
hoses to uh to guide it back out into
the ocean thank you
foreign
is again shark-free
but before anyone can relax another
white shark gets even closer
out of the water oh my God and on to the
beach
it's a great white Invasion
this youngster is alive but in trouble
after the receiving tide left stranded
unable to breathe on land
locals work fast to help it back into
the water
[Music]
[Applause]
don't get in the water you guys don't
get too close they're incredibly
inquisitive animals even juvenile great
whites have this almost this curiosity
that that's never satisfied
this curious shark swims off to make a
full recovery
but this usually open ocean species
leaves behind a perplexing question
why are they so close to people in Cape
Cod
new science reveals a startling fact
white sharks are seen more and more off
the coast of Massachusetts and shallow
water and a lot of the scientists think
that that's because the seals are coming
in closer and so they're they're
adapting to that and they are going
after the seals they're seeing Stingrays
and so they're getting more and more
comfortable going into shallow water
because as the climate changes as
fishing pressures increase they really
have to go for whatever food is most
available and easy to get to
while here these sharks spend half their
time in water less than 15 feet deep
quite often it's startling to humans
when they see these massive Predators
right along the beaches where
effectively most of us could wade into
at waist deep and see them
Ray whites are more versatile than
anyone ever imagined here at Cape Cod
and Beyond
good friends Dale Pearson and Eric Mack
returned from a shopping trip and see
something big in the shallows right in
front of their house and look over and I
see this gigantic
black tail like coming out of the water
it's it's massive it looks like it's
just like a whale like a baby whale
that's got itself beached right there so
I stopped the car we're looking at it he
just jumps out of the car and goes
running down to see what it is
I drive up to the house and grab my
phone so I can record it so I'm gonna
record us going down to save this baby
whale and I'm running down there now and
as I get closer I'm getting closer I'm
realizing that
this baby whale is not a whale
[Music]
I think that's a white shark
that might be a white shark
okay
we
[Applause]
that's a white shark dude huge
freaking shark bro it's a shark and it's
not just a shark it's a very very big
shark
[Applause]
holy
white shark
[Music]
oh
there's a giant white shark
there's my house
I've been living down there for you know
on and off for a couple decades I taught
my children how to swim in that bay in
front of the house I've been there
multiple times in bad water and I don't
want to believe that
I'm looking at a great white shark this
was the last place I ever expected to or
even wanted to see a great white shark
let alone a massive great white shark
standing right there next to a shark
that big you can feel its power we have
never seen anything
that would lead us to believe that that
kind of a predator was right there in
the water in front of the house
holy this thing's huge
oh my gosh
holy
I'm shaking
the reason for this up close visit has
nothing to do with a storm or a receding
tide
looks like it's been hit
it's on this top of the shark a really
large gash about eight inches long and
maybe about three inches deep right
behind the dorsal fin
as he starts to move away from me and
flex his tail
I notice blood coming out of the womb
whenever sharks get injured their first
thought is self-preservation it is get
as far away from anything that might eat
me or hurt me
and so a lot of times injured sharks
will go up into canals or shallow water
to kind of recuperate
sharks do have the amazing ability to
heal extremely quickly so really all
they need to do is stay alive stay fed
and then just get a couple of days to
heal before they can go back out and
resume their normal behavior
they can regenerate their flesh at rates
far faster than most marine mammals are
capable of for example
but what they need to do of course is
conserve energy to be able to trade off
that whole healing process which is
energetically expensive
the injured great white moves around in
the shallows for the next few days
before it heads into the deep
injury is a key reason why a shark may
show up on your doorstep
and it's not just great whites that seek
Refuge
a thresher shark invades the shallows
the most dangerous thing about a
thresher shark is its tail
it uses its tail to stun its prey and
that's just really dangerous for both
fish and for humans
this thresher shark is clearly not
hunting
like the great white it needs to recover
from an injury
[Music]
is gone
half of the shark's pectoral fin is
missing possibly from a boat strike or a
bite from a bigger shark
its chances of survival are high
sharks have more genes dedicated to
blood clotting and growing new tissue
than any other fish bird or mammal
so that quick recovery is really an
evolutionary advantage that allows them
to get back out there after a major
injury very quickly
bye buddy
hope you find your way back into the
ocean
bull sharks can invade a golf course
after a storm
and follow the food chain to the back
step of Riverside homes
great whites will come in close out of
curiosity oh my God
or to recover from injury
but there are even bigger sharks
invading even stranger places
an unexpected visitor draws a crowd
I see this massive Shadow swimming
around in a harbor and all of these
members of the public in awe of it and
for a split second you can't help but
think is it a white shark
it swims perilously close to families
with children
but on closer inspection by looking at
his slow docile behavior is large gaping
wide open mouth we can see it's a
basking shark
it's the second biggest shark in the
world
the basking shark is one of three
species of shark that feed on plankton
and clouds of Plankton bring this giant
into the harbor for a three-hour visit
sharks are opportunistic feeders
hungry and there's an easy meal nearby
they're definitely going to take that up
food and bring in one big shark
smaller one
a man-made intertidal zone
now rides with 150 sharks
Hound sharks
these bottom-dwelling Hunters are true
to their name
gathering in a pack like hounds
their flat teeth can Crush shell and
Bone
so this is an example of a whole bunch
of smooth down sharks in the UK feeding
on small crab species
such invasions are on the uptick and we
may be to blame
in a small Creek right behind a string
of homes in South Africa a shiver of
more than 30 large sharks
the sharks are far from an ocean Inlet
to work
common for bull sharks but these are not
Bulls
Hound sharks again and what we see this
time is an Escape Plan
well smooth sound sharks are known to be
very thermally sensitive animals if
water gets too cold too quickly it can
also be an environmental cue to vacate
the area which then caused smooth hounds
to enter the river to escape the very
very cold water in the bay
the unseasonally cold water may have
been caused by man-made climate change
elsewhere our role in causing shark
invasions is clearer
local resident Janelle branhauer notices
something bizarre in her backyard key
I saw tips of fins hundreds of tips of
fins and it was amazing it was like what
is this you know is this Armageddon
you know we frequently see fish in our
Canal we see dolphins we see Manatee but
never ever have we seen sharks and
literally there was hundreds of them
like you maybe could have walked across
the canal on the backs of these sharks
that's how many sharks were in our Canal
it was amazing
initially I first see Bonnet head sharks
and they're three to four feet which was
concerning but when I see the larger
species of fish including the lemon
sharks and the nurse sharks I know that
there is something going on that's not
right this is not normal
cause is around the corner chemical
spills and runoffs in the area
contribute to one of the worst red Tides
an algae bloom in 50 years
it sucks oxygen out of the water and
spreads through Tampa Bay
they're suffocating they have no oxygen
so they're in search of oxygenated water
and that's what brings them to this
canal that's on my doorstep
craziness
another red tide
sharks in our backyards are becoming
more common than ever
food tides and turmoil all can place a
shark in a body of water near you the
question is what
do about it
an unlikely answer can be found in
Sydney Australia when real estate agent
Melissa hathier hears about a shark in
her local Oceanside swimming pool I'm at
home it's a regular October morning
beautiful sunny day and the phone rings
and it's mum and mum's saying there's a
shark in the Rock pool what no what's
the shark doing in the Rock pool and I
said let's go Nan needs help
we get down there and there's a bit of a
crew down there and we finally see him
and I said mum someone's got to help him
I'm gonna get in and she's like you're
not getting in that pool with that Chuck
and I said no I am so I'm just gonna go
watch because I could see he was only
you know about a meter long and I
thought he's not going to hurt me let's
just swim around and see what he's doing
it's a blind shark
a type of carpet shark endemic to the
east coast of Australia that can
actually see very well it only closes
its eyes when out of the water
flat teeth and a vice grip can Crush
shell and Bone
[Music]
when he comes past me I'm realizing he's
really quite distressed because he's
kind of doing laps of this rock pool
he's bumping into the rocks and I'm
thinking the poor baby you know he's
just stuck
so he's washed in with a really super
high tide and now it's low tide and he's
probably thinking how do I get out of
here
and I thought okay if I can get a grip
around your neck at some point where you
can't twist around and bite me I think
we're going to be okay
I took him straight over to the side and
checked first is there plenty of water
on the other side there was throwing
back over and then it was just like
celebrate I was I was so happy that I
did it
Melissa didn't end up in the emergency
room
but life and limb are more at risk when
it's a deadly shark in your pool
[Applause]
it's another beautiful morning in Sydney
for a swim in the local pool
not today
manly pool has been closed by a great
white
and animal rescue expert hope Nugent is
on the scene there is hundreds of people
around this pool everyone's on looking
absolute Fascination it's not every day
that you see a great white shark in a
swimming pool big crowds gather to get a
glimpse of one of the ocean's apex
predators swimming just feet away
how this great white came to invade this
local pool is a surprising story of
shark compassion it started with a call
to rescue initially Indian report came
through as a mako shark had washed up on
the beach
upon arrival there was that moment of of
shock at the realization that it wasn't
in fact a mako shark it was you know a
great white it was obvious it was in a
really bad way and it needed help it was
too weak to battle the surf zone just
needed to get him into some still water
so that he could continue to swim rest
and the closest Still Water was the
oceanic pool just around the corner and
most people when they hear the words
sharp coming through they move out of
the way
whenever you have animals in a small
space where they can't escape and
they're under stress they're a lot more
likely to lash out than they would be if
they were able to swim away so when you
have that fight or flight if they can't
flee if they can't get away their next
option is to fight which is where
negative interactions can happen
we were there in the water with the
animals to guide it away from the
concrete structure so it didn't do any
further damage to its body
it never even factored into my thinking
that because this animal was considered
potentially dangerous or deadly that I
wouldn't assist it
in recent years more than 50 percent of
all fatal shark attacks occur in
Australia
but this shark isn't demonized
it's saved the majority of people at the
scene they are fascinated they're
wanting to ask questions they're wanting
to know what's going on
um you know it's not every day that a
great white shark washes up in their
backyard on their on their local Beach
the shark at manly was placed in the
pool by humans rescued then returned to
Sea
it's a different take on what to do when
sharks invade our space
[Music]
but in South Africa it comes with a
warning
caution
here another great white shark clashes
with locals
Lifesaver Rico Koon surfs and works in
this ocean every day
it's eight o'clock in the morning it's
turning from low tide to high tide so
it's pulling back and pushing up at the
same time very dangerous time of day and
it's spring tight so it's very very big
swell and coming in
these Surfers are used to seeing sharks
the relationship between sharks and
servers is really interesting Surfers
spend a lot of time in the ocean they're
they're really excited and passionate
about conserving the ocean because they
use it so heavily but because Surfers
are in the ocean a lot they have more
negative interactions with sharks
nobody expects what comes next
my co-worker is walking there patrolling
and then I I see him coming running back
to me and he's calling this a shark
there's a shark you must come you must
come and so I I started running there I
see the shock is laying there in the on
the Rocks it's bleeding it's hurting
itself
um and something needs to be done now
it's gonna it's gonna die how are we
gonna get out
you know when I saw the shark I saw it's
not the usual sharks that we see we see
pajama sharks in the shy kind of sharks
quite often just coming into the bay for
a little rest but when I saw the shark I
saw that this thing is massive this
thing is powerful so
um I think once I got to it I realized
you know this is this is a great white
when I saw those eyes you know those big
black eyes I realized this is a great
way
the shark is at the surfer's mercy if
they leave it to fend for itself death
is almost certain
the tide pushes it further up the rocks
and the shark can't breathe
sharks can survive out of water for
varying lengths of time if we're talking
about a larger shark like a white shark
or a hammerhead we're talking about a
couple of minutes
I do believe that this young shot was
just foraging for food it probably ended
up navigating too shallow perhaps a rip
current or some kind of stream just
pushed it into an area that was
basically Rocky with the tide going out
it was bad luck on the Sharks part I
think some people some were scared
because they realized you know Victoria
Bay is usually a safe Bay and now
there's great whites there
while it's not a huge shark its presence
calls for Urgent action
Rico is compelled to help
the tide forces the shark back towards
the beach
we don't want the shark to die how do we
save the shark without it biting us
you can put on my board one slip and
Rico's hand could end in a mouthful of
teeth made for slicing feels dangerous
to walk the white shark but in the
moment saving it outweighs the rest
hopefully it will be grateful and just
stay out of the lineup for now
it's out
[Applause]
when I did pick up the shark and here
the bystander freaking out I I remember
just realizing what I'm actually doing
right now
and when the shark smiled at me and I
saw those Thief
I gained the healthy respect that this
is a predator and not something to be
missed
dangerous predators at our feet
sometimes due to natural events
[Music]
Rising Tides
storms the hunt for food
or injury other times because we
unwittingly invite them with a changing
climate and pollution
they need to escape life-threatening
situations sharks don't seek us out
they are coming closer
and when they show up we can cringe in
fear or try to set things right and lend
a helping hand the
choice is ours
[Music]